et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
marc fesneau bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos ministes de la
déléguée aux relations avec le parlement
et à la participation citoyenne
on va revenir d'ailleurs là-dessus
puisque ça a été rajoutée à votre
portefeuille avec le remaniement
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représenté
par fabrice veysseyre dont du groupe
ebra bonjour fabrice gens reviennent
dans son jour un mot sur ce qu'on vient
d'entendre et la réponse de jean castex
et hier devant les sénateurs sur jean
castex qui était interrogé sur la
nomination de gérald darmanin est ce que
gérald darmanin il est un problème
politique pour ce gouvernement
non je ne crois pas du tout c'est un
atout il a été très actif et très
efficace dans son poste précédent et je
pense qu'il sera très actif et très
efficace tenant son poste au ministère
de l'intérieur après le mini le premier
ministre a rappelé simplement ce qu'est
l'état de droit et l'état de droit dans
ses principes et dans son application
je pense qu'on est dans un moment où on
perd parfois pardonnez moi de
l'expression le nord sur ce que sont les
grands principes qui doivent s'appliquer
à tous les citoyens de la même manière
et de la mène la manière la plus légale
entre les citoyens et qu'au fond ce qui
est de l'engagement d'une procédure
judiciaire
le préalable d'ailleurs au fonds dont
nous ne vaut pas acte définitif et que
donc la présomption d'innocence elle est
valable pour tout le monde mais vous
parlez de nous parler d'égalité
votre ami politique françois bayrou
s'était trouvé dans une situation
judiciaire compliqué au moment où il
avait été nommé ministre il avait quitté
je la place vengeurs je rappelle qu'il
avait fait le choix lui même ou à gérer
man 2 seulement dans un moment de 1
espèce de tourbillon médiatique qui
avait ce qui est déclaré sylvain
darmanin
mais moi je pense qu'il faut aussi au
fond je me dis avait créé avec recul que
il faut il faut pas céder à ce que sont
les principes républicains chaque fois
concède avec vos principes républicains
celui là en est un il y en a des tas
d'autres on pourrait discuter de ce que
sont les principes républicains autour
de la police et de la défense de son
action est différent différentes sources
de la nature je pense qu'à chaque fois
qu'on cède aux principes républicains
ont fait reculer la république et donc
il me sens que c'est important de
rappeler ce que sont ce qu'est l'état de
droit ce que sont les obligations des
uns et des autres est ce que ce sont des
principes républicains
quand vous dites avec le recul ça veut
dire que françois bayrou pouvait l'être
démissionner toujours vides non il n'y a
pas des durs et il a fait un choix
personnel il a considéré que ça pouvait
d'une certaine façon nuire à l'action
gouvernementale il portait un texte sur
la moralisation de la vie publique et
donc on voyait bien les amalgames qui
pouvait être fait à l'époque
moi je connais la probité de françois
bayrou donc ce n'est pas ça qui était en
cause n'ont rien que dans le tourbillon
qui parfois nous entraîne collectivement
et là c'est pas la question de françois
bayrou on peut être entraînés à ne pas
essayer de prendre le recul nécessaire
pour regarder ce que sont les faits ce
qu'est l'état de droit ce que sont les
principes
je pense que les citoyens ils sont ils
sont très recherchés de que les
parlementaires les élus les hommes
politiques les ministres respecte l'état
de droit et respecter l'état de droit
c'est tout respecté de l'institution que
la présomption d'innocence vous pensez
que c'est top pour gérald darmanin
comment pardon vous pensez que cette
table pour le ministre de l'intérieur
oui la commission allez on va parler du
discours de des discours de politique
générale de jean castex
il a prononcé le mot territoire 25 fois
devant l'assemblée nationale 30 fois
devant le sénat il était à ce point
oublié les territoires avant son arrivée
non je ne crois pas mais je pense que
c'est important qu'on y réaffirme dans
la phase qui va s'ouvrir parce qu'on
voit bien qu'on a fait devant nous une
crise économique et sociale qui va
concrètement avoir un impact dans les
territoires je vois dans mon propre
département ce que sont les premiers
comment dirais-je les premiers impacts
de cette crise économique et sociale et
donc il ya à la fois la nécessité qu on
fasse travailler les territoires elle
est à moi je tue toujours malheureux
quand je vois un peu des fois des hiatus
ou parfois des querelles qu'on essaie de
nouer entre l'état entre la politique
gouvernementale et les collectivités
locales je pense que collectivement nous
avons une responsabilité c'est de faire
en sorte de répondre aux attentes aux
inquiétudes des citoyens et aux
problèmes qu'on a devant nous quand vous
avez des problèmes
l'entreprise qui se retrouvent en
difficulté on a besoin de la région n'a
besoin des intercommunalités on peut
avoir besoin des autres structures
locales et donc il faut qu'on essaie de
travailler ensemble s'empêche pas qu'on
ait des différences d'approché mais je
pense que cette question là est
importante la deuxième question c'est je
pense que y compris la crise des gilets
jaunes elle a révélé aussi le sentiment
pour un certain nombre de territoires
d'être les délaissés de la république
d'être en périphérie au fond de ce que
pouvait être la dynamique économique ou
ce qu'on appelle la mondialisation et
donc il ya besoin aussi de reconnecter
au fond ces territoires à la république
les territoires ruraux les territoires
urbains et territoires périurbains
il ya un certain nombre de gens qui ont
le sentiment que les choses se passent
sans eux parce que depuis vingt ou
trente ans et ça je suis toujours
fasciné de regarder ce qui nous donne
des leçons aujourd'hui sur les moyens de
l'hôpital sur les moyens des services
publics sur les dessertes ferroviaires
qui a fait le choix si ce n'est ce
gouvernement de dire le tout tgv on
arrête parce que c'est le choix qu'ils
avaient fait les gouvernements
successifs depuis 30 ans 40 depuis 40
ans on avait dit on va faire de grandes
lignes tgv
ça a été un atout d'ailleurs et c'est un
atout on le voit bien dans la question
de dérèglement climatique à quel point
ça permet de se substituer à l'avion
mais en même temps quand on a fait ce
choix là on a fait le choix de jeu doit
dans ma propre aux régions on a fait le
choix de délaisser l'entretien et les
dessertes ferroviaires et donc là aussi
c'est une question territoriale et donc
les gens ont vu les gares tgv fleurir
ici dans un territoire avec très peu de
desserte puis après c'était envoyé
passer les trains si je peux dire on
regarder passer les trains au propre
comme au figuré et donc que c'est ça qui
est accro il a échoué à parler à cette
france est ce que jean castex vous
pensez qu'il peut l'armée je crois pas
qu emmanuel macron et les choix faits à
parler c'est france je pense que
collectivement
il ya un certain nombre de gens qui en
ont joué d'ailleurs en dix ans l'équipe
gouvernementale ce qui est totalement
faux
les élus à l'assemblée nationale ce qui
est aussi totalement faux ne sont pas
des gens qui sont connectés au
territoire
ce ne sont que des urbains enfin moi je
peux je pratique très régulièrement les
députés de la république en marche vous
dire c'est les gens qui sont à quoi
s'est connecté qui vivaient dans les
territoires l'effet du non cumul et
c'est surtout d'ailleurs je suis assez
d'accord avec vous je pense que là on
est dans le premier quinquennat de
qui vit le non cumul qui le vit au sens
concret du terme et donc à une
interrogation à voir c'est à dire que au
fond moi j'étais plutôt d'accord avec la
l'idée d'arrêter de cumul des mandats
encore que c était très restrictif
on peut même pas être adjoint mais il ya
des faits seraient peut-être quelques
effets part il ya des effets pervers
parce qu'on n'a pas pensé
le système où l'écosystème politique
avec des parlementaires que nationaux et
au fond quand il était à la fois
parlementaires nationaux est un peu dans
des exécutifs
il avait un regard sur ce que faisait
nationale et puis porter une part de la
responsabilité collective
donc là on a fait des interrogations on
a deux mondes qu'il ne s'attendait
interpénètrent plus comme unité à des
interrogations à voir ça veut dire qu'il
faut retravailler
mais sur celle ci est censée lui mais la
fin du cumul comme la fin du cumul très
bien principe général et on n'a pas
regardé ce n'est pas l'erreur la seule
erreur qui est fait le con qui a été
fait dans le quinquennat précédent je
pourrais vous parler pendant 10 minutes
du découpage des régions
là aussi on n'a pas du tout mesurer les
effets là aussi de périphériques qui a
été demandé aux gens qui sont dans la
grande région nouvelle aquitaine demandé
aux à ce qui était qui était en limousin
auparavant dans cette région s'ils ont
le sentiment que par sept grandes
régions ils ont le sentiment d'être plus
reconnecter territorialement ou pas ben
non la vérité que l'on demandé dans le
grand est à la hausse aux habitants de
charleville mézières aux habitants de
strasbourg s'il se vivent la même région
donc mais je reviens sur cette affaire
de cumul on a l'idée on pouvait la
concevoir mais qu'on n'ait pas pensé le
système en se disant comment ce qu'est
ce que ça va avoir comme conséquence et
c'est valable pour tout le monde est au
fond quand vous croisez alors ils le
disent à bas bruit mais quand vous
croisez y compris des députés qui ont
voté la fin du cumul des dix on a
peut-être été trop loin et trop fort et
pas penser ce que c'était le système est
donc ça c'est un travail qu'on a devant
nous qui est un travail de dorée
arrimage de la démocratie représentative
local avec la démocratie représentative
nationale ce qui s'est passé vous parlez
des élus qui sont accusés de déconnecter
du terrain ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières heures à la fois le propos du
président de la république son discours
en face son interview à la fois cette
cet échange houleux dans les jardins des
tuileries à paris entre le président il
s'agit des jeunes est ce que est ce que
c'est ça vous inquiète
est ce que ça vous ça vous rappelle que
on n'a pas fini encore avec avec cette
crise sociale au delà de la crise
sanitaire alors on n'en a pas fini avec
cette crise sociale et malheureusement
on n'y rentre de plain pied puisque on
en verra on verra les conséquences
économiques on peut pas avoir
je parlais de la crise sociale de l'idée
au gilet jaune au nord mais juste pour
ça que je vais le distinguer il ya une
question de crise sociale le général et
auquel il faut qu'il faut qu'on fasse
passer le premier ministre très
utilement rappeler que c'était à la fois
des grandes mesures nationales et puis
après c'était territoire par territoire
qu'il fallait essayer de trouver des
solutions parce que notre argent dans
son obligation c'est de se battre c'est
de se battre pour les citoyens pour
faire en sorte que territoire par
territoire on fasse face qu'on dise la
réalité des choses et des difficultés
qu'on essaie d'y répondre
la deuxième chose c'est pas une question
de crise sociale c'est que moi je
l'avais dit au moment de la crise du
gilet jaune qui révélait ce que j'ai dit
sur la question d'un périphérie du
sentiment d'abandon mais qu'ils
n'étaient que la sédimentation final si
je peux dire du problème du processus
en revanche il y a un certain budget
pour ça que les responsables politiques
portent une grande grande part dans tout
ça il faut faire attention aux mots
qu'on emploie quand on met à mon jettent
à la vindicte populaire un gouvernement
des parlementaires y aussi des
parlementaires qui ont été très attaqué
y compris dans leur propre domicile
personnel
on a tendu les rapports et ça ça n'est
pas lié à ce gouvernement c'est pas les
au président de république un certain
nombre de gens quand il dit on va aller
à l'elysée tetra il faut que nous dans
nos propos on soit toujours vigilants à
respecter à la fois le débat
démocratique et la nécessaire
controverse et en même temps à faire en
sorte qu'on ne cherche pas des boucs
émissaires et qu'on ne cherche pas des
boucs émissaires intuiti personae
et ça c'est pas une affaire de crise
sociale c'est une affaire d'être de
crise démocratique
c'est plutôt comme c'est pour ça que je
séparer les deux sujets une sens que
nous avons un président de la république
est très actif qui est aujourd'hui à
bruxelles pour pour faire en sorte de
défendre des intérêts français si nous
arrivons et si un accord est obtenu
c'est un accord qui sera pour
l'essentiel du score a construit le
président de la république avec la
chancelière merkel bon ça c'est des
éléments qui sont extrêmement positifs
pour l'avenir et donc il faut faire
attention à ne pas caricaturer les uns
et les autres il faut faire attention à
ne jamais accepter dans le débat
démocratique
la vindicte l'agression fusse-t-elle
verbal parce que quand vous commencez
par l'agression verbale on ne sait
jamais où ça s'arrête
et donc je pense qu'on peut avoir des
joutes oratoires vous m'avez jamais
entendu d'ailleurs être autrement que
dans ce registre là c'est à dire on peut
dire des choses on peut même dire des
choses assez sérieuse voire désagréable
le poids des mots mais le poids des mots
et moi je pense que quand on est
responsable public en haut responsable
de comment dirais-je on est aussi
responsable de l'ordre public au fond et
de ne pas dire jean alesi en gros tout
est possible non tout n'est pas possible
parce que je pense qu'il ya une le
respect d'un site des institutions c'est
le respect aussi de ceux qui les
incarnent
et c'est valable pour la présidence de
la république c'est valable pour le
sénat c'est valable pour l'assemblée
nationale c'est vrai pour tout le monde
au fonds pour respecter les institutions
on va parler du calendrier parlementaire
il ya beaucoup de choses à dire d'abord
puisqu'on est sur ces questions des
territoires une loi organique sur la
différenciation c'est-à-dire
l'expérimentation dans certains
territoires a été annoncé en conseil des
ministres avant la fin de l'été elle
sera inscrite dans le calendrier
parlementaire dès la rentrée elle sera
inscrite dès la rentrée et dès que le
sénat aura procéder à son renouvellement
donc en octobre on est en train de caler
le calendrier permettrait pas pouvoir
vous en dire plus parce qu'il ya quand
même pas mal de véhicules législatifs et
vous permettrez donc dialoguer avec les
deux présidents des assemblées parce que
c'est comme ça que ça se passe et c'est
bien normal mais je crois que j'ai déjà
dit sur votre plateau mais c'est
évidemment c'est l'horizon
parce que ça permet tout de suite de
donner des premiers signaux autour de
cette question de la différenciation
c'est un texte qui est porté par
jacqueline gourault et qui est un texte
à mon avis utile parce que c'est un
regard porté de façon différente sur la
question de la décentralisation au fond
qu'est ce qu'on a fait pendant 20 ans
n'a fait de la décentralisation très
centralisé c'est à dire on a dit dans
toutes les régions de france
la compétence transport sera géré par
les régions bon mais est-ce que la
compétence transport et la même chose
quand vous êtes en région ile de france
que quand vous êtes en région rhône
alpes auvergne en région centre val de
loire non est ce que là ya pas des
capacités qu'ils fassent qu'on dise
balas et peut-être plus tôt les
départements et que les opci là c'est
plutôt les régions là c est donc cette
différenciation c c'est une façon de
regarder le rapport au territoire comme
il en rapporte de différences de
situation est donc de ré différence de
réponse sur la question du budget du
plan de relance est une priorité pour le
gouvernement le sénat qui examine
ce week-end le troisième projet de loi
d'urgence pourquoi ne pas avoir mis les
mesures du plan de relance dans ce
troisième budget rectificatif à ce que
le gouvernement n'était pas prêt mais il
vous aura pas échappé une chose je les
dis est évoqué tout à l'heure il ya un
débat budgétaire européen une partie du
plan de relance y compris français mais
d autres pays européens il est lié aux
débats qui vont avoir lieu ce week end
y compris en termes de moyens
budgétaires donc ne mettons pas la
charrue avant les boeufs comme disait
l'autre et donc attendons de regarder
les moyens dont disposera notre pays en
termes de relance et après on aura des
outils de relance on peut nous faire
tous les griefs de la terre je sais que
c'est un exercice ce pas vous qui le
faites mais en général assez commode
pour les oppositions s'il ya bien un
pays qui a été extrêmement réactif sur
les mesures économiques dès le 17 mars
au fond dès le 17 mars
je rappelle que la loi sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
j'avais procédé aux navettes emplacement
d'un certain nombre de collègues elle
prévoit des mesures économiques dès
cette date là dès ce moment là on a
identifié ce que pourraient être les
problèmes mais au fur et à mesure on a
rajouté on a complété on a amplifié les
dispositifs qui était proposé donc on
sera au rendez vous voyez bien que
d'ailleurs vous avez plusieurs faces
vous avez l'urgence absolue qui était de
sauvegarder tout ce qui pouvait l'être
les emplois les situations personnelles
la question sociale les entreprises
vous voyez que les secteurs qui
repartent assez naturellement parce que
c'était simplement un stop and go
encore que le simplement soit un peu
crade caricatural puis vous avez des
secteurs qui sont durablement lourdement
est structurellement impact et je pense
au secteur de l'aéronautique
l'aéronautique c'est les avions qui
volent mais c'est tous les sous
traitants toutes les entreprises et jean
il y en a dans tous les territoires de
france où vous n'allez pas dans un
territoire de france riez pas des gens
qui travaillent dans l'aéronautique est
donc là vous avez des sujets
structurelles et donc vous avez des
mesures de plus moyen et long terme
autre sujet de réforme les retraites
conférence sociale aujourd'hui le
premier ministre soit les partenaires
sociaux dans l'allée renom ont
en panne pour la présidentielle est ce
que cette réforme elle est possible
avant la fin du quinquennat
alors d'abord si à chaque fois qu'on dit
on rentre en campagne on fait plus rien
je dois reconnaître car certains israël
c'est la présidence je dois reconnaître
qu'un certain nombre de nos prêts ses
prédécesseurs ont mis se sont assis
tranquillement dans le fauteuil sans
plus jamais conduire la voiture dans les
dj 18 derniers mois d'un quinquennat
m'enfin déjà si dans un quinquennat on
ampute un tiers de ce temps là à se dire
attention élection présidentielle je
pense qu'on fait défaut à la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre c'est de
rendre tous les jours outils jusqu'au
dernier jour donc la réforme irait les
mains la réforme des retraites serait
possible d'avoir la fin du quinquennat
il appartiendra le premier ministre soit
les organisations syndicales et la
partie en achetant ce que c'est une
responsabilité collective c'est pas
qu'une responsabilité du gouvernement à
la fin de l'année on va pouvoir avoir
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros
de déficit sur les retraites on peut
faire semblant le mettre sous le tapis
et dire on en parle dans deux ans une
fois que on aura au fond pas dit aux
français la vérité des choses on leur à
raconter des balivernes
pendant les la présidentielle et après
la déception sera au rendez vous ce
gouvernement le président la république
on a toujours fait en sorte de dire les
choses telles qu'elles étaient le
gouvernement d'edouard philippe et le
gouvernement de jean castex
on a toujours fait en sorte de dire il
ya des difficultés faut qu'on essaye de
les résoudre ensemble et donc sur les
retraites on a un sujet à la fois
structurelle d' équilibre budgétaire
celui qui me dit qu'il n'ya pas de sujet
et budgétaires sur les retraites je
crois qu'il faut qu'ils regardent que
ceci est une table et ceci est un micro
c'est une réalité factuelle et 2 est ce
qu'il ya des éléments
comment dirais-je qui font que les
femmes en particulier les carrières
hachées un certain nombre de gens sont
au fond n'est pas exclue du système en
tout cas sont ceux qui sont victimes
d'un système qui ne fonctionne plus bien
qui n'est plus assez égalitaire oui et
donc ces questions là étant sur la table
il faut continuer de les poser et de
regarder ce sens une région différente
mais oui mais c'est pas parce que ces
deux réformes dif différentes qu'il faut
vous avez entendu le ça veut dire une
réforme paramétrique pour régler ces
questions financières sera mise sur la
table avant l'amérique latine un four
c'est l'objet de la conférence sociale
s'est posé sur la table les sujets qu'on
veut essayer de résoudre avec avec les
partenaires sociaux
et il faut être deux je disais c'est à
dire que je pense que
au fond on peut faire on peut faire
grief au gouvernement avec un s
successifs mais il faut aussi que si on
veut que la démocratie syndicale la
démocratie organisée syndicales puissent
elles aussi être un partenaire il faut
qu'elle puisse trouver des voies de
compromis ça s'est trouvée sur le ségur
la semaine dernière il ya un certain
nombre d'organisations qui ont trouvé un
accord avec le gouvernement
quand on arrive à faire converger des
points de vue gouvernementaux des points
de vue syndicaux je pense que c'est une
bonne nouvelle
c'est toujours une bonne nouvelle on va
parler de l'écologie un barbara pompiers
qui a dit hier devant les sénateurs qui
auraient des groupes de travail avec
vous un sur les mesures de la convention
citoyenne
à quand le projet de loi qui retranscrit
ces mesures de la conçoit on va regarder
parce qu'il ya plusieurs véhicules de
possibles il ya d'abord il ya des choses
qui ne sont pas d'ordre projet de loi
qui sont d'ordre réglementaire bon pour
écrire les mesures d'ordre réglementaire
sachant que dans les propositions de la
convention citoyenne et des mesures qui
sont assez écrite est assez finement
écrites et d'autres qui portent plutôt
des principes et donc il faut écrire
paris sas à quelle échéance de travail
vont se mettre en route la durant l'été
après il faut voir il ya la question
dans le calendrier parlementaire de
regarder à l'automne ou au début de
l'année suivante les choses qu'on peut
qu'on peut inscrire mais la volonté du
président de la république et du produit
et du gouvernement qui a exprimé barbara
pompe ils essaient de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait une traduction législative
donc groupe de travail cet été et au
parlement janvier alors plus tard c'est
dans ces horizons là il faut qu'on garde
dans le calendrier parlementaire parce
que vous aura pas échappé qu'il ya un
moment budgétaire qui occupait par
l'exemple de boonen ne parle bien du
monde qui occupe le plus de temps à son
exercice budgétaire
c'est une donnée française c'est très
bien en tout cas c'est ainsi et donc il
faut qu'on fasse en sorte de conte soit
au rendez-vous de la promesse initiale
qui a été fait à la convention citoyenne
de la promesse qui a été faite par le
président de la république en sortie
quand il devant les conventionnelles si
je peux dire il s'est exprimé pour dire
voilà l'ensemble du regard que je porte
sur vos propositions
je pense qu'ils sont on attend je pense
que les français sont en attente et je
pense que par ailleurs il ya un certain
nombre de mesures qui sont nécessaires
et donc il faut qu'on travaille avec eux
sans procrastiner comme on dit mais avec
le temps qui est nécessaire pour affiner
des dispositifs et il y aura des
traductions
par exemple ils veulent je crois qu'il
porte très haut à juste titre la
question de la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments ça c'est des éléments
qu'on va avoir dans le plf sur laquelle
très vite eu d'yeux du référendum parce
que pour qu'il y ait référendum il faut
que l'assemblée nationale et le sénat se
mettent d'accord sur un texte commun
notamment sur cette question de la du
réchauffement climatique la lutte et de
la protection de la biodiversité est ce
que vous êtes confiant sur le fait que
le sénat de droite va voter de manière
pourquoi pourquoi en fait le fait qu'ils
soient de droite pourrait nuire à la
confiance je veux dire c'est pas la
question qui soit droite question c'est
est ce qu'on peut trouver un terrain
d'entente j'aurais peut-être d'ailleurs
la confiance sur ce terrain d'entente
alors attendez je rappelle d'ailleurs
que sur cette question de la révision
constitutionnelle l'article heures ils
étaient déjà rédigé puisqu'il avait été
voté à l'assemblée nationale et que nous
y avions introduit la question du
réchauffement climatique donc je veux
dire les la convention citoyenne a
repris et c'est heureux et j'en suis
heureuse que nous les parlementaires
jeudi j'allais dire nous parce que
j'étais à l'époque parlementaire et
rapporteur du texte à vous inscrire dans
le texte
2 est ce qu'il y aura des débats et que
senna oui alors est-ce que je suis
confiant par nature je suis confiant au
sens premier du terme c'est à dire je
fais toujours confiance au dialogue à la
capacité qu'on a convergent et après
c'est à nous gouvernement c'est tôt à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat dans
un dialogue que je pense qui peut
déboucher d'essayer de trouver une
rédaction une formulation qui permettent
de d'être là dessus mais de vous à moi
je pense qu'il ya aussi c'est d'ailleurs
tout l'exercice auquel s'est livré le
premier ministre dans son discours de
politique générale est aussi besoin de
mesures concrètes parce que c'est très
bien de mettre en son article
il faut veiller à lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est mieux si
bien de l'écrire c'est mieux de le faire
et donc au fond si on investit
puissamment dans l'e mobilité décarbonée
si on n'investit plus à man dans la
rénovation énergétique si on investit
puissamment pour faire en sorte qu'on
préserve
à certain nombre de choses en terme de
biodiversité je pense qu'on fait une
oeuvre aussi très utile de nécessité qui
est la nôtre c'est d'être au rendez vous
non pas des promesses et de te
rendez-vous du concret puisqu'on parle
de ces conventions citoyenne le
président de la république dit on
souhaitait d'autres il ya la
participation citoyenne qui a été ajouté
à votre portefeuille
est ce que c'est un moyen de mieux faire
accepter aux parlementaires c'est
convention citoyenne
la question n'est pas de faire accepter
aux parlementaires je pense qu'ils sont
plutôt vers les uns et les autres sur le
sujet mais vous m'avez toujours entendu
y compris à son micro dire qu'il ne
fallait pas opposer démocratie
représentative
le sénat l'assemblée nationale parce que
les procès d'une légitimité qui est
quand même formidable en démocratie
c'est que les gens ont voté
c'est un peu idiot de rappeler ces
principes là mais je pense qu'une
démocratie où on vote parce c'est un
problème voyez ce que dira d'ailleurs ça
ne s'appelle plus une démocratie et de
on a besoin de nourrir et de dans un
dialogue qui soit un dialogue fructueux
et qu'il faut qu'il faut inventer parce
que la france n'est pas très rompu à
l'exercice et la convention citoyenne
est un exercice très innovant pour la
france et même au niveau mondial sur un
sujet aussi vaste
il faut qu'on arrive à trouver les voies
d'un dialogue et c'est pour ça que c'est
intéressant que ce soit dans le même
périmètre ministériel d'un dialogue
entre des citoyens qui peuvent exprimer
des choses c'est valable à héros
national ça pour dire que c'est valable
locale d'un dialogue qui permette de
faire feu alimenté la démocratie
représentative de la démocratie dite
participative
je pense que c'est us et utile il ya un
besoin d'appropriation des sujets sont
très complexes il ya des contraintes qui
pèsent sur les uns et les autres et donc
il faut qu'on essaie d'y travailler et
donc je trouve que c'est une à bonn
c'est une bonne oeuvre que de faire sa
dernière question oui remaniement
ministériel vous en avez fait partie il
ya quelques jours c'est pas tout à fait
terminée en attendant et secrétaires
d'état
ça peut se produire dès ce week-end on
peut avoir la liste complète des
trucages des bus et les prérogatives du
président de la république et du premier
ministre
oui il nous aura pas échappé que le
président de la république et dans un
sommet européen qui est assez
déterminant est assez crucial
donc on verra en tout cas dans les jours
prochains et j'imagine à paris les 1 j
imagine que les centristes espère
mais moi je vous ne trouverez jamais sur
le chemin dans ces cas là de ce qu'il
faut c'est des gens qui est des
compétences des gens qui puissent
appuyer les ministres dans leur mission
évidemment il ya des nécessité d'
équilibre politique mais la question
n'est pas celle des centristes pas plus
que celle qui viendrait plutôt d'autres
horizons la question c'est d'avoir des
gens qu'ils soient compétents et que
chacun retrouve au fond ce que sont les
grands équilibres de la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale donc c'est plutôt
comme ça qu'il faut le regarder en
s'énervant pas plus que ça dernière
question un peu plus personnel il ya des
régionales qui arrive est ce que vous
pouvez être tête de liste dans la région
centre valent de l'or
ou comme la plupart des habitants de la
région sans je peux être tête de liste
choisie dans région sans doute est-ce
que vous en avez envie
mais écoutez on va regarder jacqueline
incertain hier sur ce plateau nous
disait que vous alliez faire campagne
que vous allez être impliquée elle et
elle et vous mais j'ai déjà vrai dans
les campagnes régionales je trouve que
c'est et ça vous à périmètre qui est
intéressant c'est ce que je vais vous
dire il faut réfléchir à ces choses là
la question talent apporte un manifeste
non non je suis d'accord mais non et je
vais pas vous faire de la langue de bois
je ferme pas la porte je trouve que
c'est un c'est un espace qui est un
espace intéressant pour faire de
l'aménagement du territoire là ces
choses jamais j'aborde cette question
des régionales dans cette région comme
dans les autres avec l'idée qu'il faut
qu'on essaie de porter quelque chose qui
soit hors du champ partisan je pense
qu'on a besoin de construire des
majorités qui dans les régions puissent
non pas forcément être complètement
aligné avec la position gouvernementale
mais au fond qui ont envie dans un
dialogue fructueux de travailler avec
l'état l'état celui d'aujourd'hui et
celui de demain aussi et donc il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire c'est une
région qui n'a pas subi si je peux dire
et quand je dis subi je pèse mes mots
au fond de fusion nous font qui a besoin
de retrouver aussi peut-être son unité
parce que c'est une région qui est très
diverse dans ses composantes et donc on
verra
il ya un remaniement la semaine dernière
vous me parlez déjà des régionales de
l'an prochain
il ya des créations on aura l'occasion
pardonnez moi de vous dire que c'est
peut-être que je n'irai pas en parler
sur votre plateau et si je dois en
parler quelque part ça sera peut-être en
région si vous permettez
on espère quand même cette digression
mais je suis assez fidèle au poste chez
vous donc il n'y a pas de difficulté
d'ailleurs vous avez été le premier
invité de cette saison de foot merci à
la clôture merci merci beaucoup merci
mais non